you've got to circle any circle these
one can be a bit smaller because we're
not going to put such a huge number of
things on them okay draw a circle any
circle and then what I'm thinking to do
is onto your circle
I'd like you to draw a pair of chords
but here's what I want you to do with
these chords specifically can you just
make the chords the same length make the
chords the same length so maybe they're
both going to be two centimeter chords
but in different spots maybe something
like over here and over here okay you
can make them short you can make long
you can make them overlap you can make
them not touch each other like mine
don't once you've made them the same
length and it'd be really nice by the
way if you had these different to the
person next to you
I then want you to join from your chord
the shortest distance from your chord to
the center of the circle I'm not going
to draw it in just yet I wanted you to
give it give you a moment to try to tell
yourself you've got two chords here two
chords here and we'll give them some
names shall we let's call this one a B
let's call this one CD you've got your
Center oh I want you to draw a B join a
B and C D to the center in the shortest
way possible Q do that I'll give you a
second to catch up make sure you've got
everything labeled out
yeah Jake so you've got two cords
there's the same length so maybe
underneath this you maybe want to write
chords a B and C D are equal
okay we'll label them as equal in a
second we're enjoying up your chords to
your Center I said the shortest length
the shortest length between a point and
a line is not just any length it's the
perpendicular right that's the quickest
way across just like crossing the road
the quickest way across the road is
straight across the road don't take it
in an angle
okay so if you join these up and you
mark in the right angle which indicates
that's the shortest distance you can get
remembering that I didn't give you any
instructions about how long to make your
cause I just said make them the same I
didn't tell you where to put the chords
I said put them any way you like I want
you to have a look at these two lengths
that you've just drawn let's call them
om and om when you look at it you can
almost see and when you measure it you
should be able to confirm what do you
notice about these two lengths they
should be equal they should be equal so
I'm now going to mark in that CD and a B
are the same and along with that or m
and om are the same okay
so how could we word this what's the way
that we can describe what's going on
okay we started by saying equal chords
equal chords
what are they what do they share in
common how would you describe the fact
in words verbally that these two
distances are the same we want to make
this as succinct as possible use a few
words as you can still it again okay
just watch out we've got all these
features here I want to point out I
haven't drawn any radii on this circle
right there are no radii that have been
constructed because I have never joined
the center to the circumference I've
gotten close but I haven't okay I could
make it even more obvious that I haven't
by putting these chords close up so the
center is obviously not a radius okay so
how would you describe what's going on
here equal chords are so again remember
we try to use as few words as possible
I'd probably say that then they're the
same distance from the center same
distance from the center the word I
would use is equidistant okay now I
apologize we sort of doing this a little
bit in slow motion consists of the very
first chord property that I'm mentioning
you guys going to do this on your own
for some of the later ones how are we
going to prove that this is the case
like it looks true you've measured it
well within the limits of your measuring
instrument it looks pretty true but how
can you prove it you remember we had a
look at the polar lines and transversals
last time we said it looks good
measured it we all tried it but we
proved it using logic how did you prove
that this is actually the case anyone
want to make any suggestions salient
okay we could with a bunch of pythagoras
pythagoras is a sort of logical way to
go because you see right angles however
it's also illogical because actually no
triangles so would you like me to put
some triangles on here yeah
what triangles really like measure on
tell me you've got words you've got
labels tell me what i need to join up
see and oh like that send off
do I need to turn up anything else a and
here dude is that enough what do you do
with that do that remember we don't know
anything else at a circle we're going to
have a lot we're gonna have a long list
of these eventually but right now we
don't know anything else apart from the
fact that it's a circle what else really
good whoa what parallel lines so you're
suggesting this perpendicular line
bisects this Court is that what you're
saying okay now as it happens this is a
property where you can get to that
perpendicular line does bisects the
chord but I don't know that yet I am
going to prove that as we go and then
once we proved it we can use it but I
don't know if that's the case just yet
if you want to use that fact that's okay
but you're going to have to prove it is
there anything else I could do
yeah what perpendicular formula are you
referring to you guys tell me I don't
know any formula called the
perpendicular formula I just want to
point to you I want to point this is
really interesting okay our diagram is
not finished what I'm suggesting it's
not finished I'm going to give you two
or three minutes there's a few different
ways to have godness I want you to think
about all of the plane geometry
knowledge that you developed over the
last week and a half or so that's the
reason why we led into that to get to
circle geometry how would you prove that
this is the case because it certainly
looks like it why don't you take some
time I'll give you a heads dot if you've
got an idea rate down set it out as a
proof like you normally would see how
far you can get off you go so admittedly
part of what's tricky here is we're
right at the beginning is topic so I'm
trying to assume as little as possible
so some things which in coming days
you'll just treat as a given I'm not
treating them as Givens yet for instance
the fact that n is in fact in the middle
of CD it's right above it bisects that
chord but we're going to prove that
we're not quite there just yet
so here's what I'm going to do we
constructed Oh a and Oh see these two
radii what I'm going to add on to there
are B that radius and also do you don't
have to do it this way but it just seems
like a pretty straightforward way to go
I'm trying to prove something about
distances right distances so therefore
when I think about the knowledge that I
have that allows me to prove distances
are the same I need to prove entire
shapes of the same entire shapes are the
same that's congruence isn't it
can you see why for example similarity
is no good for proving something like
this
well country's similarity most of the
properties about intercepts for instance
are about similarity but here if you
want to prove that distances are the
same distances and similar triangles are
not the same they're in proportion so
that's not what I'm after
okay so what I've done is I've
constructed all of these radii and now
I've got a pair of triangles
they look pretty congruent right can I
prove that they're congruent I can't
can't I would you like to call these
triangles let's call the top one a a B
oh and if we're doing it in the same
order down the bottom C D oh I'd guess
right because you've got you can see
these guys are the chord so the
correspond to this court or fine in
these two triangles what if I go well a
B does equal C D that's the way that we
actually constructed this that's where
this diagram comes from okay so I can
say that's given right I'm going for
Congress what other kinds of features do
I have that I know are the same yes good
so most of you have spotted I do have
all of these radii that are equal to
each other so I'm going to go for a Oh
being equal to a looking at the letters
because I did the work up here to make
sure the letters are in the right order
I can just quote the letters in the same
order down here
they're radii similarly and we use this
way at any time the reasoning for what
I'm about to say is identical to the
reason that I just said similarly what's
the other radiant radii that I have I've
got
and do right so therefore what's my
particular congruence reason as SS okay
so now I know that these two train will
are exactly identical in every way
they've just been shuffled around
rotated a little bit as it turns out so
how do I get to the thing that I want
because it's pretty much the next lines
what's the reason I think I heard it so
you can't say anything about
corresponding sides because i ôm and Oh
n are not sides in this triangle okay
however I can say if Oh M is equal to N
or the reason why M is equal area is
because both of them are perpendicular
heights
and importantly their corresponding
perpendicular home because we know
there's actually different ways you can
refer to the height of a triangle I
could have drawn it this way and made it
perpendicular as well would be just as
valid but they're the same orientation
right you can see everything matches up
so oh man I am perpendicular heights in
congruent triangles okay that's all you
need to say okay now I want you I'm
going to stop talking at you because I
just wanted to show you what I was
talking about here I want you to now
file this away as true I can rest on
this now it's proven so I can use this
as a further tool in my toolbox you've
got a few other core properties they
start from page 347 or 347 on the
textbook I don't know what it is on the
PDF you can see we proved the the first
one chord and distance from the center
one of the really nice things they are
pretty much every circle property is
that the converses are also true what
was the converse of this theorem bead or
property how would you state it in
reverse
what do you think
yeah that's you you got all of that
you've got the order right any other
sentence a little bit awkward but I put
you on the spot the whole idea here was
we started with equal courts and then we
concluded something about their distance
from the center okay well to say the
converse is to do that in reverse order
so the way I'd say it you're not going
to put this underneath as well is if you
have chords and they're equidistant I
should have started with the word chords
sorry
chords that are equidistant from the
center by the way not just equidistant
from whatever
if you know this this is what we start
with then necessarily and if you enjoy
yourself in your circle and try this out
right if we make chords that are
equidistant from the center but
necessarily they are equal in length
themselves right you can't not have that
happen
so the converse of this is also true
kind of like Pythagoras interestingly
enough